what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
7 death prediction video if you missed
my last video about which characters I
think will die next season definitely
check that out as soon as you can I'll
put that link down in the description
also but let's get right into today's
video because there are several more
characters that I think are going to die
during season 7 there will be some
spoilers and leaks in his videos so
proceed with caution the first character
on this list is beric Dondarrion
berrak is a member of the Brotherhood
without banners who is most likely
heading north of the wall on a mission
from the Lord of Light the cold winds
are rising and the dead rise with it and
I think Barret will be killed by the
night king or his army Barristan Darion
will go north of the wall with a group
of characters next season and during
this mission he will be killed
Barrett's final role in the books was to
bring lady Catelyn back to life now they
obviously aren't going to be doing that
in the show so beric is definitely
running around on borrowed time he will
be one of the characters that are killed
on this mission to raise the stakes and
make it more dramatic and even a more
intense and life-threatening situation
12 characters might go beyond the wall
but 12 characters will not be coming
back unless they come back as a white
bears dawn Darion died in the books and
he's going to die in the show they
should send him off in a good way though
since he sacrificed his life in the
books for someone else to live hopefully
he will be able to do the same thing in
the show but since we're talking about
the Brotherhood without banners I might
as well go right to the next character
from this group that I think is going to
die which is Thoris of mirror
Thoros will also be on this same mission
next season with beric Dondarrion into
hound we solve Thor's of mère in Iceland
with Gendry getting ready to film scenes
that are going to be north of the wall
the plot leaked actually said that doors
of mayor would get attacked by a zombie
polar bear and that's how he will die
obviously I'm not sure if it's going to
happen like that but either way I think
you will be killed on this mission as
well it would be awesome if we saw a
polar bear fighting at the 19's army but
it's hard to say if they're going to
spend money on that kind of CGI even
though I think beric Dondarrion and
Thoris of me are going to die I also
think we will see them again as whites
fighting for the night King we will be
seeing some characters we are familiar
with get turned into whites without a
doubt and these two characters will be
some of them next on the list is your
hey Joey she is currently sailing the
Westeros as a part of Danny's fleet but
before they even set foot on the beach
at Dragonstone they will be attacked by
Euron Greyjoy we got a glimpse of this
battle taking place in the new trailer
and as you can see it's going to be one
hell of a fight your own can fail them
to see just as good as the Dothraki can
fight in the open field during this
battle one to see your great joy will be
taken prisoner by euron greyjoy she will
then be taken at King's Landing most
likely as an offering to Cersei
Lannister I think there are a few
different ways Yara will end up getting
killed as soon as you're on hand sir
over the Circe she could end up being
executed right away or she could get a
more slow and painful death that can be
administered by the mountain but I also
think Theon may try and save her
Theon's character is still in the
process of completing his story arc and
I think a way for him to do this is to
try and do the unthinkable which is
getting behind enemy lines and saving
his sister something fian does not
appear to be capable of right now but I
think he will attempt to save his sister
just like Yara tried to say Theon
when he was a prisoner of Ramses only I
think you're amazing
this rescue attempt somehow I think this
rescue attempt will get botched just
like Yara's did when she tried to get
beyond back beyond we'll probably be
very close to freeing his sister but
then she will be killed right in front
of him and this will be the tipping
point for Theon the driving force to get
him to kill his uncle you're on
unfortunately for Yara she may be the
sacrifice to get Theon's character to
finally snap out of that reach hit and
kill you're on this leads me to the next
characters that will die next season
which are all of the sand snakes the
plot league said two of the sand snakes
will die when you're on a text to flee
and this does appear to be true when we
see you're on what there's prisoners in
King's Landing he only has two of the
sand snakes with him so the other two
most likely died just like the leak says
now there is a chance they could have
escaped but I doubt it
we all know that Dorne has been a
complete [ __ ] show ever since Oberyn
Martell died when Oberyn Martell died
the Dorne plot died too
now Dan and David we're trying to take
Dorne completely out of the show and I
don't blame them I think once the sand
snakes are killed we will never see or
hear about Dorne again
Ilario was the one who killed Circe's
daughter so I wouldn't expect her to be
shown any mercy and the sand snakes will
meet the same fate when you're on hands
them over they will be executed Kane
will definitely be killed I'm sorry but
bran will not be saving her I know some
of you think that but Dorne is about to
be extinct from this show I think Dan
and Dave are hoping they can kill
everyone off as fast as possible that
way we forget about them out of sight
out of mind
now this next person on the list really
breaks my heart to say this because he
is easily one of my favorite characters
and I am talking about none other than
tormund Giantsbane I would really like
tolling to survive the entire series but
I think John and Danny will both lose a
big character from their teams this
season we know the show is winding down
and some of these second and third-tier
characters will be killed off
unfortunately I think grey worm will die
from Danny's camp and torment is going
to die from John's camp but on the
bright side the Hound will most likely
replace torment for John's team The
Hound has a much bigger role to play in
the end but I think someone like tormund
is expendable he could be another
character that dies on this mission
north of the wall when season seven is
over we are really going to feel the
presence of the xix in his army and with
the loss of some of these characters
like torment and gray one it will
increase the urgency of John needing to
rally the realm to fight together on the
same team but I do really hope I'm wrong
about this but for some reason I just
had this feeling that John and Danny
both will lose at least one of their
best fighters this season Randall and
dick on Tarly are both going to die as
well too I forget whose Chad I was in
recently but during a recent livestream
I was talking with some people in the
chat about randyll Tarly and who he was
going to be fighting next season randyll
Tarly is currently the greatest military
commander left in the show but in the
open field against the Dothraki in the
dragons he will be defeated
Rando and dicken Tarly will both be
involved in what is most likely the
biggest battles seen Game of Thrones
will have ever done which is being
dubbed as that field of fire 2.0 we got
a shot of this battle from the trailer
and we can see Danny's army charging
full steam ahead with the massive dragon
flying above which will provide them air
so
or this is going to be a bloodbath and
randyll Tarly is going to make the fatal
mistake of choosing to fight alongside
the Lannisters against Daenerys and her
army as you can see from the league
photos that tarly's will be fighting
with the Lannisters and they're side by
side you can see them right here making
a defensive wall in the open field
but once Daenerys has her dragons
unleashing hell upon these men I do not
think they will stand a chance no matter
how great of a military strategist they
are Randall and his son Dickon will be
killed we also know Sam has one of the
biggest roles to play in the show for
the endgame and we can't have his father
running around wanting to kill him now
can we randyll Tarly will be removed
from this game without a doubt but there
is one more character that I want to
mention in this video and I think we'll
die next season and that person is
Melisandre there are at least four
different ways I think Melisandre can
die next season so what I'm going to do
is make a separate video about this that
way I can go into more details so this
will be like a little teaser for my next
video which will be about the various
ways I think Melisandre can be killed
off of the show
most people say Arya is going to be the
one to kill her but there are several
other ways that are just as likely to
happen but before I sign off I have to
give another big shout out to another
patreon supporter just the other day
Denis Chadwick donated $20 to support
the channel and at the time that was the
biggest amount ever pledged
but someone else donated last night and
a new record has been set I hope I don't
butcher your name but I believe it is
pronounced read on and they pledged $25
I want to thank you very much you have
now set the bar very high I really
appreciate the support
everyone has shown to the channel it
does mean a lot to me I hope all of you
have a great day and I'll see you all
down in the comment section bye